the return of Gordon Gekko sorta Wall
Street money Never Sleeps ain't that the
truth
alright so Wall Street one I personally
love there was a little stock market
jargony with the whole talking about the
over/under and you kind of got to know
what that stuff means in order to get
the whole movie but I liked it maybe
because I get that [ __ ] kinda woman he's
good right and now 23 years later Oliver
Stone makes the official sequel Gordon
Gekkos out of jail and he wants his
comeback and also Shia LaBeouf's in it
Shia LaBeouf wants revenge against Josh
Brolin who's the main [ __ ] this time
around and Gordon Gekkos daughters in it
who's dating Shia LaBeouf who wants a
father figure which makes him drawn to
Gordon Gekko who wants his comeback and
wants to patch things up with his
daughter who wants nothing to do with
him meanwhile this guy's like I'm a
total dick and if that sounds a little
convoluted it's probably because it kind
of is and you cannot have too many dicks
in the fire so Gordon Gekko like peach
and Smash Brothers Brawl has been
totally nerfed and has been bumped from
antagonist to antihero which would be
okay if you didn't have one third the
screen time I think he should have had I
mean come on this should have been the
story of the comeback of Gordon Gekko
which it kind of is sort of but not
really Gordon Gekkos main thing is he
wants to reconnect with his daughter
the main arc in the movie is Shia
LaBeouf wants to ruin this guy which you
kind of forget about at a point in the
movie because there's other storylines
that are going on and mostly it
concentrates on and I know someone out
there is gonna comment that Gordon Gekko
wasn't the main star the first one it
was bud Fox and Gordon Gekko was like
the hardcore supporting character
antagonist douchebag guy in the
background and I get that but I don't
see Charlie Sheen on the blu-ray cover
of Wall Street I mean Gordon Gekko is
supposed to steal the show instead you
have a movie that's divided among four
characters and no one really shines
because he tries to divide it in a way
that makes everyone relevant which means
no one is you never get the Gordon Gekko
onslaught that you've been waiting for
since the 80s there's one part where he
Gordon Gekkos out and you're like now
we're talking but it's just totally
negated by the cop-out ending there were
things that I did like about the movie I
mean Josh Brolin's great as the
douchebag this time around and the movie
takes place in 2008 which means it is
going to happen I mean you're just
waiting for it the stock market fall you
know that moment where the
News told us that the world was just
gonna end in the economy was gonna be
ruined and the machines were gonna rise
and the intro to primal rage etc which
was ultimately Oliver Stone's catalyst
into writing this movie and let's face
it if you made a movie called Wall
Street after 2008 you kind of just have
to make a follow up so I like that that
was relevant but there's a lot of stuff
that took place after the first movie
and before the second movie that
influenced Gordon Gekkos life that you
just never saw it ultimately feels like
Wall Street money Never Sleeps could be
the third movie in a trilogy like
imagine you saw the Fellowship of the
Ring and then saw Return of the King and
all that [ __ ] in two towers you never
saw but it's relevant so you're just a
little confused so Wall Street money
Never Sleeps was pretty much an average
sequel it's a fair attempt it's good
it's not great watch the first one it's
awesome so I'd say it's okay but I'm not
gonna remember it in t minus 13 hours
what movie am i talking about again if
you're a stock market buff I'd say go
watch this movie because the content
will at least interest you ironically
you need to watch Wall Street one to
understand everything that's going on in
Wall Street - or at least Gordon Gekkos
life but by watching Wall Street 1 Wall
Street - looks inferior that's a funny
world we live in but if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more than click right here to see more
[Music]